the consumer says is the meat good is it
healthy for my kids is it gonna be cheap
check I'm good to go
why should I to consumer be so concerned
about what's going on because there's a
concentration so there's an Oleg our key
of power and control at the at the top
at the top of the chain right and that
trickles down to you so they are able to
eliminate competition in the United
States while bringing in cheaper lower
quality meat from other countries 18
other countries and they can put that on
top of our meat mix it in the grind or
mix it in you know you can go to the
grocery store and you may have you may
buy a cut of beef that says product to
the USA that does not mean that it is a
product of the USA so basically what I'm
telling you is as a consumer you don't
know what you're buying you don't know
the food safety because every country
has different safety inspection
standards right now they do have to go
through a United States inspection
standard but it's not up to par as what
we have inland here so how it affects
you is is you're getting a lower quality
product at maybe a higher price because
they as a consumers at a higher price
but that ability for them to import that
cheaper cheaper cut of meat throw it in
to the American product it oppresses our
prices because there's no competition
for it so out of those 18 countries are
any one of them China yes one of the 18
is China yes
what percentage recently made a we we
made the trade deal with China on this
and this was gonna this was supposed to
have been started that you know during
this coat deal the four main trade is
Canada Mexico New Zealand and Australia
[Music]